water soil and Sun these make the
universe with ample water on good soil
warmed by the Sun crops grow luxurious
lush bountiful luscious yes on this
earth we live by water for water is life
to plants to animals to man down from
the heavens it comes water for the land
billions upon billions of tons of it
immeasurable oceans of water pulled by
the matchless power of the Sun lifted
atom by atom up to the clouds again
without water crops that once gave
promise wither in the Sun and wind water
can be the difference between life or
death production or destruction proper
handling of rainwater and melting snows
will prevent such damage as is evident
in the eroded pasture beyond nature's
own way was to cover the earth with a
protective mantle of grass trees and
other vegetation but man must till the
land to live there is no water erosion
problem on this manure livid field if
all the land were covered with
vegetation or were perfectly leveled or
if it absorbed rainfall readily there
would be little runoff but there are
slopes with soils that cannot drink in
dashing rain fast enough runoff carries
silt seed and fertilizers to the
lowlands both of the fields and into the
creeks and rivers starting ugly washes
that may someday twist or break your
equipment
this is sheet erosion the beginning of
gullies the forerunners of eventual
abandonment of the land this is the
result of faulty Park here maybe the
cause rose up and down a gentle slope
encouraging runoff in heavy or long
continued rains each little shovel mark
a channel to the sea after the deluge
the little waters have run away taking
soil seed fertility fortunately there
are effective defenses against runoff
damming one of the simplest is contour
farming tilling and planting across the
slope instead of up and down for the
best view go into the skies this is
conservation farming round farming in
square country
contouring will prevent serious runoff
in the ordinary rain a shovel mark a
wheel track row of grain level across
the slope hold the water until it seeps
into the soil where the slopes are long
or steep or on land that absorbs water
slowly contouring alone may not be
enough strip dropping another bulwark of
soil depends can be added here you have
it feels contour strip against erosion
that
this is the principle working to
perfection
each strip of field in the established
crop rotation alternating bands of small
grain row crops and grass legume hay
fields spreads squarely across the path
of runoff water in these fields you see
two vegetated water outlets the natural
depressions and drainage ways paved with
grass against the gully in effect of
excess runoff that otherwise will
inevitably occur a third line of defense
against soil erosion is the terrace in
this field you see how effectively
terraces trap the surplus water most
terrace systems are the so called
drainage type each Terrace constructed
with a gentle gradient thus water caught
in its downward race moved slowly and
safely out of the terrace and into a
protected outlet as with the terrace
system itself the outlet should be
designed with the help of a soil
conservationist your county agent an
experienced farmer or anyone qualified
to do the job we have seen three of the
main mechanical defenses against erosion
with all three of them simple contouring
strip cropping and terracing tillage is
on the contour
railways use the contour principle
trains run as nearly on the level as
possible contour farming is like that
on the level to lighten the load save
fuel and time and money farming up and
down slope is about as illogical as
running a train over the hills first up
with a hard pull
then coasting down easy wasteful of time
and fuel and energy
if your farm is even gently rolling the
chances are you can profitably use
contouring strip cropping or terracing
perhaps all free but you may ask will I
need special equipment to practice soil
conservation the answer is definitely no
you can do it with your present
equipment but many farms that are
adopting a conservation plan must be
conditioned for it
Gulley's like this wasteful and costly
to farm around can be filled quickly and
inexpensively with the disk tiller or
the moldboard plow the operator cuts the
first slice with the tiller away from
the gulley bank on successive rounds he
sweeps the loose soil in toward the
gully
round and round cut and sweep take a new
bite and sweep it in actually that's all
there is to this job
however avoid driving your outfit too
closely to ditch banks at the start but
that is not only dangerous but also
unnecessary instead you roll the soil up
to the gully edge repeat the process
until the soil falls into the ditch this
job can be hurried along by setting the
tiller or plough shallow if necessary in
order to drive faster and throw the soil
farther
when the gully is nearly full the
operator can work his outfit in closer
as the accident hazard is lessen whether
the gully filling job requires a round
or two as with a small wash or a dozen
rounds or more as in this instance the
principle of earth-moving is the same in
little more than an hour's time this
ditch was filled ready for grassing or
for cropping establishing waterways is
one of the initial steps in a
conservation plan because terraces
concentrate water thus giving it cutting
power outlet should be well established
before the terraces are constructed
the initial step in building terraces is
surveying and staking the terrace lines
again a job for someone who has had
previous experience or training with
guide stakes set a helper leads the
operator on his first round where you
start the cuts the order in which you
make them varies widely
follow the approved method in your
locality
the return trip of the first round on
the lower side of guts takes the first
complete round establishes the island
usually the ridge is built by moving
soil down from above and up from below
you want a farmable channel on the
upside a down slope that is equally
adapted to the use of modern power
equipment the terrace is taking shape
this is an earthmoving job the disk
tiller is ideally suited to it if
operated at the proper speed on this
trip the ridge is being built by
throwing the soil up from below the
tiller gives even this loosened soil a
noticeable throw number of rounds
necessary will vary with soil type
steepness of slope and other conditions
it will vary with soil that's wet or dry
Saudi or loose ordinarily 20 to 35
rounds will do the job up one side and
back on the other around and around
until channel terrace and back slope
meet the desired standard
the last wave moves up to the ridge
where the guide steaks were originally
set now we've built a terrace having a
channel as well as upper and lower
slopes that are tillable ears prove that
this terrace will catch hold and carry
away excess water ridge height and
channel cross-section exceed
requirements many farmers construct
terraces with the moldboard plow the
principle is the same survey and
stakeout the terrace Ridgeline establish
the island then move the soil in to form
the ridge speed counts here too the
faster you move the better your plow
throws the soil
this is terras construction as
accomplished by an experienced farmer a
past winner of terracing contests he
knows just where and how to drive for
best results on each round
taking a slice on the lower side
he loses no time on turns with modern
power equipment he lifts and lowers the
bottoms without even looking around down
one side and up the other sweeping soil
in to make the rig any farmer can easily
learn to do this job cutting a slice on
the outside the downslope here the plow
must throw soil uphill and back again on
the inside
he's throwing soil down slope but upward
against the upper slope of the terrace
nearing the end of the job the terrace
is almost finished and ready to prepare
for Planet
this is a terrace as built by a champion
that's what an experienced farmer can do
with the moldboard plow unless
established terraces are painstakingly
maintained watched constantly for minor
breaks channel water may overtop them
wash through as it has done in this
minor break the tiller and the plow are
good maintenance tools the return trip
on the upper side the operation here is
maintenance plowing of the terrace
combined with normal tillage operations
on the balance of the field the
operation shown here parallels the
original terraced construction simply
throwing soil to the ridge from above
and below rebuilding it replacing the
soil that has worked down from the ridge
if the terrorists area is in normal
cropping maintenance of this sort is
usually done each year
now the break the over top place in the
ridge is almost completely refilled
but that loose soil will settle with the
rains the careful conservation farmer
will watch this danger area keeping the
low spot field to prevent another
breakthrough
Tara's maintenance plowing with the
tiller is customary in the south also
the job is combined with flat breaking
of the entire field common practice in
many sections is to cut stocks into the
soil with the stock cutter and disk
Errol this view is on southern
terrorists land
and farmers in the deep south using
power equipment more and more find the
better planner well adapted to the broad
base terrace the lister works equally
well tractor and better find no
difficulty following contours or working
over the terrace ridges even in loose
soil listing on the contour is an
additional aid in holding water until it
seeps into the soil regardless of the
type of planting equipment you have it
can be used on terraced land in the Corn
Belt farmers are adopting soil saving
methods to hold their rich soil on this
completely terraced and contoured farm
the operator plants his terraced fields
easily with the to road drawn planter
how it works on terraces may be judged
from the fact that the height of this
Terrace is 26 inches at least 6 inches
higher than ordinary in this territory
cultivating corn is always a job
requiring accurate work the outfit must
stay precisely on the roll and move the
proper amount of soil into the roll
this modern outfit does that and does it
on the tightly curving contours and even
on the sharply sloping terrace ridges
when you see it done you know it can be
done
and it gets the weeds and grass
particularly that troublesome small
grass in the corn row in the south to
farmers do this ticklish job on sharply
bending terraced slopes cultivating
cotton peanuts and other crops
they do it clean fast and right
conservation farming often means more
hay bigger harvests the hey chopper
simplifies the hay making job saves
labor and cuts costs to the minimum
there is no heavy pitching with an
outfit like this on the job it picks up
all the hay around the curves and on the
slopes
remember the strip crop fields the bands
of small grain around the heels they are
no problem to the light combine farmers
find it equally maneuverable inside
those narrow strips or on the short
abrupt slopes of terraces where this
combine is working or creeping through
down grain winding its way along the
terrace
grasp waterways vital in conservation
tillage must be protected not ripped up
you need quick positive action on your
disc harrow gang modern equipment gives
that action in crossing the waterway a
touch of the hand on the control lever
straightens the game's angles them again
instantly on the other side
raising planters misters and other
seeding equipment also is necessary to
protect the grass waterway it is easily
done with modern equipment here you see
a mounted planter which is especially
adapted to contoured field that's where
your equipment maker has joined hands
with conservation for many of these
improvements were designed for
convenience in conservation farming this
is a two row cultivator operating in a
contoured cornfield the row crop
cultivators would be especially damaging
if they were not raised in crossing the
grass watercourses power lifts provide
instant raising and lowering to permit
feather edging both sides of the
vegetated outlet in soil maintenance the
manure spreader is almost indispensable
or no conservation farmer deserves the
name if barnyard manure is wasted on his
place likewise long used fuse demand
ground limestone basic slag or other
soil sweeteners having applied the line
to his pasture land this farmer now
cultivates it in adding fertilizers if
necessary these are the important
practices in pasture maintenance and
pasture renovation the legumes those
marvelous nitrogen makers are important
in soil maintenance they too belong in
conservation farming what you get out of
your soil and how long you can continue
profitable farming depends upon how you
manage your land your county agent and
your local soil conservationist can help
you farm the conservation way a plan can
be fitted to your land too and once the
plan is established your soil will be
fortified against exhaustion the land is
your heritage preserve it